this is timor saying reading for
reviewer stephen petit metroid dread is
a triumphant return for the iconic
bounty hunter samasaran in large part
because it remains true to its lineage
like seeing an old friend for the first
time in many years metroid dread is
charmingly familiar an old-school side
scroller with a modern look and feel
dread played similarly to samus returns
for the nintendo 3ds developer mercury
steam brought over the excellent counter
attack mechanic to dread as well as the
manual sighted aiming system that gives
you pinpoint control over beam shots and
missiles while dread is pleasantly
familiar mechanically samus has never
felt this good to control with a pep in
her step and tight controls metroid
dread is silky smooth in motion an
absolute joy to play
utilizing the same 2.5 d art style from
samus returns metroid dread offers
crisper more detailed visuals that help
make each of the locales and their
enemies stand out rocky tunnels molten
caverns industrial compounds underwater
depths metroid red is filled with the
distinct level designs that have marked
a series series's storied history
improved animations especially from
samus herself and bosses enhance the
overall presentation while adhering to
the signature art direction and style
the series is known for
[Music]
metroid red has been billed as the swan
song of the current samus saga bringing
a story arc that began 35 years ago to a
satisfying close was always gonna be a
tall task but dread definitely untangles
the series's web of narrative mysteries
to deliver an affecting tale that
features some of the best writing and
atmospheric storytelling in the series's
history to get there dread kicks off
with samus arriving at a destination to
investigate a mission gone awry only to
soon find herself devoid of her decked
out suite of abilities this time it's
planet zdr where the federation has sent
a robotic task force called emmy to
search for evidence that the ex-parasite
lived on after the events of metroid
fusion samus quickly encounters a
powerful chozo warrior who knocks her
unconscious she awakens deep beneath the
planet's surface far away from her ship
with only her power beam and a batch of
missiles dred flips the script by
forcing samus to travel up and back to
her ship but in practice this change
isn't a meaningful shake-up as you'd
come to expect dread requires frequent
backtracking so you're moving in all
different directions throughout the
adventure one notable new feature that
makes both exploration and combat
different than usual from the start is
samus's ability to slide this allows her
to access areas previously only
accessible via morph ball as well as
provide a nimble way to dodge attacks
the morph ball is still needed in many
instances though the winding tunnel
system in each of the themed locales
inevitably leads samus into trippy
portals signifying the start of an emmy
zone surprising no one the robots sent
to the planet to investigate have been
reprogrammed to do what all
well-intentioned robots secretly want to
do kill emmy zones introduce stealth to
the metroid formula and it's a mostly
positive addition the emmy which crawl
on all fours along walls reconfiguring
physically to chase you through spaces
you'd think they can't navigate are
positively creepy inspiring the dread
the title alludes to if an enemy spots
you a chase sequence commences and if
you aren't able to outrun it it can be
instant game over you have a very brief
window to execute a perfect counter
which stuns the emmy and gives you an
opportunity to slide under it and escape
but the timing is extremely tight and
the window seems to vary to ensure
escape after capture feels like a stroke
of fortune pretty early on you unlock a
useful clocking ability that makes you
invisible which can be used to evade
emmy and pass through motion locked
doors but like the counter it isn't
enough to trivialize the emmy
nevertheless exploring an enemy
patrolled zone can be nerve-wracking but
it's never nearly as terrifying as it
could have been mostly because the
stakes are low if you get caught you
simply get sent back to the entrance
emmys wind up as more of a cumbersome
obstacle at times mainly because the map
layer often forces you to zigzag through
emmy zones to make progress and
backtrack coming across an emmy guarding
the exact exit you're searching for can
be tiresome especially since the
encounters are mostly the same
throughout in isolation emmys bring a
well-designed new element of gameplay
into the metroid fold but in the grand
scheme of things they can get in the way
of what metroid is all about careful and
thorough exploration
inside each zone is a floating orwellian
eyeball mini boss that once you're able
to find can be destroyed to receive a
one use omega cannon the process for
killing an enemy has two steps exposing
its head by shooting away the shield
with a machine gun and then charging up
the cannon to deliver the kill shot the
kill sequence is a clever puzzle of
sorts which is presented from an over
the shoulder camera perspective you have
to find a clear enough space in the zone
to shoot the enemy at a distance and
make it vulnerable otherwise you have to
start the process over from a different
spot with each successive emmy encounter
the process for killing then becomes
slightly trickier thanks to
environmental obstacles that force you
to think and act quickly despite the
intermittent annoyance the
moment-to-moment gameplay evolving emmys
is still enjoyable even if it feels
somewhat at odds with metroid's core dna
thankfully emmys aren't an overbearing
presence they are more of an aside the
vital framework of metroid is still
intact and dread handles exploration and
backtracking better than any other game
in the series thus far dread feels like
a more adventurous take on fusion's
cadence you still get mission updates
from the ai adam in network centers but
very rarely does it tell you exactly
where to go instead there's a clever
nudge in the right direction while still
giving you the freedom to explore though
i did get lost for a brief bit twice
throughout the adventure once i figured
out where to go i started to recognize
the subtle suggestions in both writing
and environment that point you in the
right direction dread doesn't hold your
hand it feeds you drips of information
and new abilities to allow you to
gradually explore previously unreachable
areas and exploring is the name of the
game here dread has more secrets to
uncover than its predecessors there are
missile packs all over the place
including upgrades that add a whopping
10 missiles to your ammunition capacity
dread might actually have too many
missile packs as i eventually had so
many that i didn't even need to be
concerned with being accurate with my
shots during late-game boss battles
energy tanks on the other hand remain
critical finds in addition to full
energy tanks mercury steam has added
energy tank pieces
four make a full energy tank quadrants
of the map with hidden collectibles
flash after you've visited them to tell
you there's something to be found but
not in a way that makes finding upgrades
any less rewarding speaking of the
in-game map it's deliciously detailed
marking every single location where you
picked up or saw an upgrade as well as
points of interest and doors that
require specific weapons to open you can
highlight specific icons as well as drop
pins at spots you want to circle back to
while the map can get a tad busy as you
make significant progress it does help
make the backtracking even after you
finish the story a worthwhile and
engaging endeavor of course exploration
is tied to samus's abilities and dread
features a plethora of upgrades old and
new there are more than 20 suit weapon
and ability upgrades in dread and almost
all of them are required to fully
explore the map for instance the various
suit allows samus to withstand heat in
fiery areas while the wide beam opens
certain hatches and moves large boxes
it's not uncommon to find multiple
upgrades in an hour your means of
exploring evolves quickly consistently
giving you more reasons to retrace your
steps and voyage to new sections that
said because of this constant barrage of
new upgrades it sometimes feels like you
barely make use of your newly acquired
gadgets this is especially the case for
beam upgrades which replace your
existing beam one of the new morph ball
gizmos is only really required once
immediately after finding it so
sometimes it can feel like dread really
suffers from a gluttony due to uneven
pacing of unlocks that clutters late
game sections dreads handful or so of
locales are wonderfully designed to test
both your platform and combat skills and
each has its own stable of enemies that
pack a hearty punch samus returns really
elevated metroid's combat with counters
and dread continues that many enemies
from flying monsters to hulking land
beasts have an attack that can be
counted and successfully slaying a
monster following a counted attack drops
more health or missile resources
rewarding you for making use of this
vital mechanic dread adds to the series
history of great boss fights with some
of the most daunting duels of samus's
bounty hunting career the best boss
battles like the showdown with a chained
up larger-than-life crate make you feel
small and powerless at first tasking you
with figuring out how to evade an
onslaught of attacks timing counters and
laying into the beasts with a flurry of
missiles
dread does sometimes fall into the same
rut as samus returns with repetition of
many bosses albeit not such to an
extreme degree more than anything else
metroid dread feels like going back to a
place of comfort after a long time away
though the gameplay is refined and new
features have been added to the mix
dread sticks closely to the formula of
his predecessors in the end for long
time fans like myself that's probably
for the best there's nothing to dread
here we're home again
[Music]
you